et annette a rencontré rue voisine nous
ce qu'on a envie de savoir
parce que christophe toi tu me rappelles
tu es sorti avec toutes les meufs de la
série alors mais sans rigoler lui c'est
un truc de fou d'elle sans rigoler et
même des mof fixé 3 dans la série
c'est un truc de ouf je sais pas toi je
sais mais est-ce qu'il ya eu non égalée
couple est ce qu a eu des frais jean-luc
je ne sais pas parce que jean luc ne
ment pas on était les spectateurs ont
besoin de savoir
honnêtement honnêtement je pense était
une des séries sur le plan des coupes
les plus sages y avait plus de place à
ceux pêchés ça je peux chanter plus sûr
est l'année des gaziers tellement plus
grand c'est normal c'est ça la là
c'était plutôt calme gentil s'était
ainsi que samir haouet j'ai pas qu'est
ce qui est à 10h et pas de quoi personne
n'est sorti que justin mais non mais non
non mais oui j'ai fait de la figure pour
premier baiser
un jour une demi journée j'étais payé
500 quand je me souviens et je jouais
une correspondante italienne eh ben vous
savez une à l'image regarder non bah
ouais bon d'accord ils ont plus de cours
que nous on a je suis pas sûr que ce
soit pour ça tu vois
comme elle est plutôt jolie j'avance
semble plus particulièrement bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on n'est pas tellement un petit
entre vous et vous j'étais comme des
options hathaway genre n'est pas
heureusement parce que je paye tout
comédienne mais voilà et c'était bien
parce que je me suis acheté dans une
agence de mannequins et on cherchait des
petits boulots et s'était payé donc 500
francs à l'époque c'était énorme talent
caché et j'avais passé une demi-journée
dans les studios